die laufenden diskussionen um den
möglichen einsatz einer uno
friedenstruppe im dom bass in der ost
ukraine oder den bestehenden einsatz auf
dem golan dürfen immer wieder die frage
auf wie nützlich wie sinnvollen
friedenseinsätze sind dabei wird oft
übersehen wie unglaublich sich die
rahmenbedingungen verändert haben seit
1948 der ersten friedensmission heute in
vechta kompakt sind friedenseinsätze
unverzichtbar ob die uno mission im
libanon eu soldaten in bosnien
herzegowina oder nato truppen im kosovo
und soldaten der afrikanischen union in
somalia friedenseinsätze sind aus dem
sicherheitspolitischen alltag nicht mehr
wegzudenken
sie sind ein wesentliches instrument der
internationalen staatengemeinschaft für
frieden sicherheit
allerdings haben sich die
rahmenbedingungen unglaublich verändert
das ist einerseits zurückzuführen auf
die eigenen häufig sehr negativen
erfahrungen auf das geänderte politische
umfeld und auch auf die gestiegene
erwartungshaltung gegenüber
friedenseinsätzen ein wesentliches
element dieser veränderung ist der
konflikt trend so haben die bewaffneten
konflikte und gewaltsamen krisen 19.90
rasant zugenommen
heute mehr als 200 dieser krisen und an
die 35 bewaffneten konflikte kriege die
sich weltweit jährlich ereignen
der großteil davon ist innerstaatlicher
natur der zwischenstaatliche krieg ist
die absolute ausnahme geworden und das
hat erhebliche auswirkungen auf das
internationale krisen management die
drei prinzipien form zustimmung der
konfliktparteien von unparteilichkeit
und von gewaltverzicht rücken immer mehr
in den hintergrund weil friedenseinsätze
andere aufgaben dazu bekommen haben seit
1990 können wir grob drei phasen bei der
entwicklung der friedenseinsätze
unterscheiden wichtig dabei ist sie
reflektieren einerseits die
geopolitischen veränderungen und
machtverhältnisse auf der anderen seite
auch die werte und vorstellungen und
normen die durch friedenseinsätze
unterstützt oder durchgesetzt werden
sollen
die phase eins von 1990 bis 2001 war
geprägt von den zerfalls kriegen in
jugoslawien und blutigen kampf fanden in
afrika nur einsätze nach bisheriger
fassung waren nicht mehr ausreichend
denn schließlich ging es jetzt zunehmend
um den schutz von zivilpersonen um die
verhinderung von
menschenrechtsverbrechen von genozid und
dazu brauchte man auch entsprechende
robuste mandate man ging daher vom
kapitel 6 auf kapitel 7 über das heißt
soldaten im dienste der uno dürfen die
waffen auch zum schutz von zivilpersonen
verwenden die unsere grenzen gestoßen
sie hat nach unterstützung gesucht wie
die nato auf dem balkan die fatalen
terroranschläge von lionel leben führten
zur zweiten phase der friedenseinsätze
nun ging es darum staaten aufzubauen
afghanistan und kosovo es ging um
demokratisierung es ging um
wirtschaftliche entwicklung man wollte
hier wirklich unglaubliches voranbringen
dazu wurden viele akteure ins feld
gebracht zivile wie militärische uno
einsätze
neben angels die koordinierung dieser
internationalen friedensoperationen
wurde es sehr schwierig und hat auch die
grenzen der machbarkeit aufgezeigt die
zahl der missionen unter eingesetzten
soldaten stieg ebenfalls mehr als
100.000 soldaten waren im namen der uno
unterwegs und über 130000 unter nato
flagge die enttäuschenden ergebnisse in
afghanistan
die zu haben wir vom gewaltsamen krisen
die umbrüche im arabischen raum und auch
der flüchtlings andrang richtung europa
haben zu einem gewissen umdenken im
bereich der friedenseinsätze geführt man
wollte nicht mehr so ambitioniert sein
denn eine demokratisierung und eine
transformation kann nur von innen kommen
aber nicht von außen
daher lautet der neue strategische
ansatz hilfe zur selbsthilfe ist nicht
wirklich neu ist ein alt bekanntes
modell
dabei geht es darum kapazitäten vor ort
zu unterstützen aufzubauen im
politischen bereich im zivilen bereich
und auch im militärischen im
sicherheitsbereich
das geht nur mit partnern partnerschaft
diese ein wesentliches element ist es
nur ein strategischen ansatzes das heißt
einbindung von der regionale
organisationen zb ecowas in afrika
der ambitionen sind gesunken die
ressourcen sind gesunken auf westlicher
seite von seiten russlands und chinas
und auch brasiliens ist zu erkennen dass
sie sich verstärkt im internationalen
friedenseinsätzen engagieren welche
trends zeichnen sich daher bei
friedenseinsätzen ab die erwartungen
werden bestimmte reduziert sein so etwas
wie in afghanistan wird man nicht mehr
versuchen die anzahl der akteure nimmt
deutlich zu
das macht andererseits aber die
koordination vor ort wieder schwierig
lokale und regionale organisationen wie
in afrika gewinnen sicher an bedeutung
und der gradmesser der internationale
friedenseinsätze wird in zukunft sicher
sein ob es gelingt den schutz der
zivilbevölkerung sicherzustellen
bei aller skepsis und berechtigte kritik
gegenüber friedenseinsätzen zu stellt
sich doch die frage was wäre ohne sie
denn zweifelsohne haben sie dazu
beigetragen dass konflikte beendet
wurden das waffenstillstandsabkommen
eingehalten wurden pufferzonen
eingerichtet worden
monetäre hilfe und wiederaufbau
ermöglicht wurde
österreich und das österreichische
bundesheer haben hier immer einen
wesentlichen beitrag geleistet und
werden es auch in zukunft tun
angesichts einer komplexeren welt und
der zunehmenden zahl von gewaltsamer
krisen werden friedenseinsätze ein
wesentliches element der internationalen
sicherheitspolitik bleiben